hello everyone and welcome to round four
of the uh sinkfield cup uh it is a game
that i'm sure a lot of you guys were uh
very eager to see it is han smokin eemon
versus alireza firuja and yesterday hans
defeated magnus crossing with the black
pieces which is an incredible feat
and now uh he if he can pull off a win
against aleris that will truly be
amazing but as you guys know how strong
is that is much easier said than done so
let's dive straight into it it's quite
the game and it's it's it's a very
complicated one uh hans with the white
pieces opens with e4 we have e5 vial it
is a knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to c4 hans goes for the italian
game and the alireza strikes back with
the two knights defense now i know a lot
of you who
were hoping for a knight g5 here that's
always um very enjoyable but on the top
level they play pawn to d3 so this is
the sort of modern bishop weight uh
modern bishop's opening way of treating
the two knights of defense with bishop
to c five valeresa and now c3 uh d6 and
now both players castle so castles
castles and the rook to e1 and we often
mentioned that okay you leave your f two
pawn uh sort of attacked but the knights
the g4 is is nothing to worry about you
can just play rookie two and then kick
away the knight but even though it's
nothing for example in 2019 levon
arunian defeated even charity with this
exact idea so you have to be ready for
it in case someone drops it and usually
uh you will see a6 here or a5 but here
alireza goes bishop back to b6 so he
switches the move order a bit and tries
to confuse hans hans goes a4 now he
wants to of course play a5 b4 uh and
alireza stops at pawn to a5 with h3
stopping ideas like bishop g4 and h6 now
we have knight to a3
the usual idea being that you want to
execute d4 move the bishop back and then
remaneuver the knight to c4 going after
the bishop on b6 so here 97 and uh there
are some games that read this position
bishop to b3 is a known move but here we
have d4 by hans the immediate d4 and it
is now as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game uh so let's see how
alexa handles this uh you could capture
it right away if you capture it right
away let's say c captures in d5 this is
sort of the the main theme of the of the
pawn push on d4
let's say e5 attacks the knight knight
e4 and then bishop back to d3 so it can
be played this way where the knight is
hanging here and there are ideas where
you could even sacrifice a pawn here or
you can just defend it with a move like
f5 or bishop to f5 and the game
continues uh but instead all it is it
just goes knight to g6 and okay now
bishop back to f1 the bishop is always
useful on f1 in
positions like these because it's a
really good defender and also like we
mentioned you want to clear the c4
square to get your knight back into the
game so c6 we have knight to c4 and now
bishop to c7 and now uh
has a very strong bishop player here
eyeing that king side and also the
knights are very nicely placed d
captures on e5 knight captures an e5 and
now bishop to f4 putting more pressure
on that e5 square so knight captures on
f3 queen captures and now all alireza
finally executes d5 and um of course uh
hans will not react to this he will just
bring his last inactive piece into the
game and that is the rook on a1 so rook
a to d1 and all it is it just goes
bishop to e6 adding another defender to
the d5 pawn and here there are a lot of
moves you could consider you could
consider queen g3 with some ideas of
attacking the bishop uh also putting
some some pressure on the h6 pawn it's
not that relevant as long as the bishop
isn't c7 but it is it is a possibility
you could capture on d5 you could play
some like rook to d4 try and double up
on the d file uh but hans goes for e5
which is uh very very nice as it uh no
you no longer have to worry about the
dark square bishop you're kicking away
the knight and then you might have some
ideas of maybe sacrificing on h6 who
knows maybe some nice rook lifts are
coming in uh anything is possible and if
all it is it goes knight e4 you can
challenge it one knight to d2 so alireza
goes back knights to d7 puts more
pressure on the e5 pawn and now we have
queen to g3 and here
alireza has a very very difficult choice
to make is this is this even a threat
and can he capture a knight here i'm
going to show you what happens if you
capture the knight even though it was
not played in the game uh because it's
uh it just seems like too complicated
the move d captures on c4 if you play
this then comes bishop captures an h6 of
course threatening checkmate so you have
to defend with the g6 but now not
grabbing the rook rather bishop to g5 uh
the threat is if the queen moves and
that would be a pretty bad thing uh you
want to capture the knight here the
defender of the f6 square and this is
now sort of winning by force the bishop
captures bishop f6 threatening queen h4
and checkmate and the only defense is
bishop d8 you threaten the bishop queen
g5 uh bishop captures now pawn captures
again you're threatening queen h6
followed by queen to g7 checkmate and
now if queen to d6 preventing queen h6
because of queen captures on f6 then you
play rook e4
and now yes black is getting destroyed
for example rook f38 rook h4 now with
the threat of rook h8 check sacrificing
the rook then queen h6 check followed by
queen g7 checkmate uh queen of f8 stops
this idea and now you have this bishop
captuson c4 move everything is working
beautifully here queen captures on g6
being the threat and after bishop to f5
stopping this now rook h6 and there is
no stopping rook captures on g6 you
could try something like rookie 6 to
give up a little bit of material but
white will always be winning this bishop
captures if captures now comes pawn to
g4 bishop d3 and queen h4 uh there is no
stopping this you are losing the queen
however you play this even if you go
something like this then rookie seven
checking eight and rook h8 will win the
black queen and the game so this is what
happens if after bishop the g5 you would
move the queen but after f6 ended this
is possible uh then the game continues
and it's uh i mean you could play this
uh
with black but for example bishop h6 now
of course you have to prevent queen g6
then g5 bishop captures king captures
now queen f3 putting more pressure on
the file as the knight here cannot move
so bishop d5 attacking the queen and
unpinning from the rook queen to h5 and
now knight captures an e5 so i mean this
is just uh it's hard to even look at
this uh this and if queen to h8 check
king to a7 and
now we would probably see a repetition
queen h7 check followed by a repetition
or even if queen h7 checked maybe
alireza could play king to d6 and then
continue the game uh but i mean it would
be
it would be very interesting but already
did not wanna go into all of this so he
just played king the h8 he know now no
longer has to worry about bishop
characters on h6 but now the knight is
no longer on the table uh or rather you
know you know what i mean uh knight to
d6 and now this is just a monster knight
here and it's very very difficult to
deal with this salazar plays knight to
c5 he wants to bring the knight to e4 to
sort of threaten the queen and go after
the knight and here hans played rook to
d4 uh supposedly c4 is winning here uh
but it's uh
or rather maybe even close to winning
maybe something where hans could just
play for the win but it's very very hard
to see problem is uh
uh the the knight is not greatly placed
on c5 basically you want to play bishop
characters and then after pawn captures
play queen e3 the problem is you can't
play this right away if you play play
this right away captures captures and
queen e3 you attack the knight and the
h6 pawn now king h7 is possible and
after queen captures on c5 there's this
annoying bishop to b6 that's the problem
you have to move the way all the way to
a3 and then queen h4 and uh
it's not that easy to to play this or
you know uh
yeah
it it it's not as clean however if after
knight to c5 you first play c4 then it's
a it's a bit different now all it is it
does not have a great move here uh as
knight to e4 is no longer an option if
of course knight captures uh
d captures uh you you lose the queen so
basically the idea is after c4 is played
elitist can play something like knight
captures on a4 but now comes uh this c
captures on d5 c captures and now pawn
to b3 you chase the knight away
back to c5 or b6 then bishop to d3 and
you get a very nice attack so basically
the main line is knight to c5 bishop
captures g captures and queen e3 now uh
going after the knight and here if you
want to prevent queen captures on h6 now
you really really have to play queen g5
and then queen captures and see five
leaves hunts with a with a spectacular
position
uh but okay hans played rook to d4 uh
it's uh of course impossible to see
everything and now we have uh bishop
captures on d6 so it is a happily gets
rid of this monster knight he captures
on d6 and not 94 going after the queen
preparing to win back the pawn uh but
han says not today he plays rook or
rather this rook captures knight on e4
he gives up the exchange to mess up um
uh there's a spawn structure in the
center win upon and then uh have a
beautiful pass pawn on d6 and maybe even
some sort of an attack against the black
king so the captures on e4 we have rook
captures on e4 and now queen to f6 by
alireza and now bishop to d3 uh you
could also consider bishop e3 trying to
get that bishop here or or maybe even
try and uh
you know uh have it ready for bishop to
b6 if the rook ever comes to d8 then
maybe you can put it on c7 attack the a5
pawn so this is all in the position hans
goes bishop to d3 right away and now uh
alice just goes bishop to f5 so he
manages to trade off some material
rookie three bishop characters on d3 we
have rook captures on d3 and now queen
to f5 attacking the rook here so queen
e3 keeping of course
the rook nicely defended and always
having this nasty threat of queen
captures on h6 and with the rook so
active it could get uh
could get ugly so hans has to absolutely
absolutely activate the rooks he plays
rook f38 attacks the queen queen d2 now
getting ready to push the pass pawn and
rook 8 to d8
we have bishop to e3 now by hans going
after this bishop to b6 move and now we
have pawn to c5 and this is basically
where the game can end right away if
hans wants it uh so uh and that is of
course by playing bishop captures on h6
so this is this is now a draw uh but as
hans uh has the white pieces uh and he
has a playable position he he he wants
to push for more the situation on the
clock is 12 minutes for hans and 28
minutes for alireza so also hans is very
low on time uh but i will show you if
what happens if bishop captures pawn
captures and queen captures there's
queen h7 and now queen f6 check just
leads to a repetition because if you
move the king there's this incredibly
nasty rookie three move that wins the
game for white now there's no defense uh
you can't capture because of queen
captures on d8 d7 is coming you cannot
stop this and everything just falls
apart uh so that's the problem uh so you
will have to just agree to a repetition
here after queen here queen to h4 check
again queen repeats queen f6 check queen
g7 queen h4 check and so on so here
instead after c5 hans wanted to continue
the game and he played g4 uh attacking
all it is queen and after the queen
moves he wants to pick up the c5 pawn so
queen the e for ballet is going after
the a4 pawn and now bishop captures on
c5 we have queen captures on a4 now it's
eight minutes for hans uh 26 minutes for
alireza and now bishop to d4 and now you
can see that it's uh getting very very
dangerous if alireza picks up the pawn
he's just uh getting destroyed the idea
of course being bishop captures and g7
check and then the the rook falls if you
do nothing then even queen captures an
h6 with check is an idea rook to d6 kind
of stops this
idea but then like i said bishop g7 just
just wins for uh for hunts and also you
could play rook to e6 to just prevent
the queen to h6 capture and this is
exactly what alireza plays
we have bishop the b6 now attacking the
rook rook to d7 and now bishop to c7 so
hans keeping his past pawn alive and the
two rooks
are are unable to do anything about this
and now the position is uh
very very complicated alireza is better
here he could push for the win here uh
but he doesn't here alireza actually
forces the game into into a quick draw
but the real way to fight here is queen
to a1 check and after the king moves
rookie one and now the king hunt begins
the reason why i think alireza did not
go for this is that after hans plays g3
alireza did not see g5 and it's uh
not g5 right away but first you're going
to play rook to h1 now prepare to bring
the queen into the game and after queen
to e2 threatening queen to e8 check to
win the rook now g5 and that's uh maybe
what all it is i missed but here
uh it would be incredibly complicated
but still if anyone can push for more
here it would be black point is that
after this check and king to g7 you
don't have a good move now now you're
just lost if you capture the the rook
here just queen f3 and there's no
defense against queen captures an h3 or
rook captures an h3 and queen captures
on d3 so very very very complicated
stuff uh but yeah after bishop c7
alireza decided to bail out he played
queen to
c6 and now uh hunts just goes for rook
to e3 and everything gets traded off the
board rook captures queen captures and
now alexis says i've had it with this
bishop fast pawn action he just captures
it captures captures and now uh
uh hans goes uh for the repetition queen
e8 check king to h7 and queen to e4 with
check you could play g6 to maybe try and
play this but uh still it's uh it's a
queen in the game uh with equal material
no point in playing this king the g8
queen they checking h7 queen to e4 which
check king to g8 queen to e8 uh and now
came to h7 and he was in this position
on mu 43 that the game ended in a draw
uh by threefold repetition uh so after
beating magnus uh he drew he draws his
game uh with alireza but what a game it
was seemingly uh hans could have played
for the win at this one moment where uh
he decided to go rook to d4 c4 was the
way to push for the win but you've seen
how complicated the line is
and also uh uh maybe alireza could have
gone for something with d captures on c4
if he accepted this peace sacrifice and
allowed hunts to go for the attack uh
but in the end it was uh definitely
alvarez who could have pushed for more
with rook to a queen a one check and
rook to a1 and started a king hunt but
again incredibly complicated with a
perfect play or even probably with
decent play it would still be a draw so
i think um you know both both are happy
with the draw uh
as the game was extremely extremely uh
exhausting and complicated uh even to
follow let alone to play i can't even
imagine how complicated it was to play
this
uh but yeah that's the game the first
we're showing from round four we're
probably going to show more and then we
are going to discuss the standings
because now that magnus left the
tournament as you guys know or some of
you maybe don't know uh the
results uh no longer matter because you
have to play more than half of the games
in the tournament for the results to
stay in the tournament now that magnus
left the tournament uh all of the games
that he played and the points uh
well that he took or that were taken
from him no longer matter he loses the
rating or wins the rating that he won or
lost but the game's games
in the tournament are are of no value
whatsoever
uh so yeah we're going to discuss this a
little bit more once we check out some
other games and then we are going to
discuss the new standings uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely done by both of them really
a wild wild game
i would like to thank wood uh thanks
paul sertanovich blitz 44 chess and csfi
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the sim field cup until it
finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day